[Applause]
from first minister to criminal suspect
in one of Scotland's most extraordinary
political sagas Nicholas sturgeon the
figurehead of Scottish government for
nearly a decade was questioned for seven
hours about what she knew the financial
discrepancies at the heart of the
Scottish national party finances after
being released she put out a statement
on social media she said she was
innocent of any wrongdoing and that she
intended to be back in Parliament after
the next day or two
sturgeon has been synonymous with
Scottish politics and the Scottish
independence movement she's got status
across the world for a long time even in
Britain she was actually Britain's most
popular politician which is bizarre
because the SNP want to break Britain up
they want independence for Scotland so
she is a she's got a large footprint for
a small woman her shock resignation in
February came just weeks after she'd
promised voters that she still had
plenty in the tank to continue in office
but the clouds had been Gathering a push
to hold another Scottish independence
referendum was ruled unlawful by the
Supreme Court in London and her desire
to make the next general election a de
facto referendum sharply divided opinion
within her own party it's the question
of what happened to some 830 thousand
dollars of party funds which has brought
police to Nicholas sturgeon's door that
money was raised specifically to
campaign for another Independence
referendum but some 360
000 of it has vanished from the party
coffers the chief executive at the time
was sturgeon's husband
in April police detained her husband
former SMP Chief exec Peter Murrell and
two weeks later it was the turn of the
smp's former Treasurer both were
released without charge it's now up to
the prosecuting authorities to decide
whether there's enough evidence to take
this matter further against any of the
three main SMP figures Paul Brennan Al
Jazeera Edinburgh